that's all you're ever gonna have fun
yeah
is there anything that you won't do like
swim with sharks again or something or
do you want to jump sharks again unless
I have a [ __ ]
protective
that's crazy too I will not I'm I'm not
[ __ ] with sharks anymore dude I'm
like I [ __ ] tested my boundaries and
luckily I still have my hand for uh
people who didn't catch the jackass
Shark Week episode I I think but
probably like a lot of people know you
got badly bitten by a shark yeah man it
was can you show the camera yeah dude it
was crazy
I know I felt bad for you guys because
you had to go through it but [ __ ] I
was just like yeah how dare you do that
that's what he was worried about in the
hospital so so it's [ __ ] still on but
dude it's [ __ ] gnarly though which
camera should he show up dude
it looks like your hand has been like
like burned like Freddy Krueger yeah
burned that's that's funny because I say
that I tell people it looks like Freddy
Krueger's face like yeah
it was crazy as Papa poops has a missing
hands same hand yeah did you know that
Steve is missing a hand yeah that's
right that's right his poop sounds took
after his dad my dad got his hand um ran
over by a train let's put into
perspective how [ __ ] obvious it was
that that was gonna happen
this was the thing
on I had to just I didn't have any
practice runs
well I mean dude if I would have got a
practice run a couple practice run with
no sharks I made it you like there's no
sharks
I mean technically if he would have
landed it and ridden away it was not
even [ __ ] amazing but okay so here's
the thing like and it really like was
like supposed to be me because the
bigger bit was a dunk tank built on on
barrels so it was floating we said that
the actual tank was the ocean with all
the sharks and I was just they had this
dunk tank with the the seat above the
like six feet above the water no cage
underneath no cage underneath just
barrels on the water and the seat's six
feet above and it's got the Target and
everyone's supposed to be throwing
chunks of meat at the Target and so that
the hunks of meat bring all the sharks
and then when one hunk of meat actually
hits the target it'll drop me into the
water and I thought when I heard the
idea I thought that that sounded like
the safest thing because when we were in
South Africa during the the great white
right yeah they said if you land on the
shark then like that's the safest thing
this it'll startle the shark like the
land in the water start with the shark
gets kind of bold so I was like oh dude
I'll be perfectly fine I'll be safe when
we get there
and there was something about these
sharks these Caribbean reef sharks
doesn't sound like a scary shark but
when we threw a piece of meat in the
water it was the gnarliest [ __ ] crop
these sharks were climbing all over each
other biting everything
about it they were the most aggressive
[ __ ] sharks I've ever seen in my life
yeah I saw a leaf land on the water and
it was oh my God remember when you were
feeding them from the back of the boat
gnarliest [ __ ] ever dude they were it
was [ __ ] it was a frenzy there
they put a [ __ ] a water ski jump ramp
in the water and now like what we're
doing is we're throwing hunks of meat
right to the to The Landing in front of
the ramp so it's just a swarm it starts
like climbing all the way to get that
[ __ ] meat what the plus it was dusk
which is when sharks are the most active
protecting we're losing life then you
don't want to swim at dusk that's the
most dangerous time we've been saying
dude it's dusk like you know and so
we're throwing the the hunks of meat in
front of the ramp where poopies is gonna
land what the [ __ ] do you think is gonna
happen every time something landed in
that water
it was like the Sharks were conditioned
oh here's we're feeding them right
something lands it's it's it's
food and so we're throwing it we're
throwing it and then the next thing that
[ __ ] lands on that water is poopies
the [ __ ] did you think was gonna happen
oh the only thing that has landed on
that water is food and then purpose is
the next thing to land he's food he gets
bitten what's the idea that he would
jump successfully
no I wanted to jump over them at least
clear them
[ __ ] hindsight it was the most
Reckless most obvious [ __ ] [ __ ] that
and and had we and we were supposed to
film the dunk tank before that and it
was the same Dynamic if I did the dunk
tank I would have they would have been
throwing everything's food everything's
food and then dropped the chair and I'm
food
when you hit the water what do you
remember
I just remember looking at the boys in
the boat and just [ __ ] dude I was just
like I'm [ __ ] boys I mean we saw the
sharks like he landed on the Sharks we
saw them just [ __ ] commotion is he
underwater and then we saw his hand come
up out of the water and dude I couldn't
say anything instantly yeah I couldn't
say nothing because I was in shock so I
like I was trying to tell him that I got
bit but I like couldn't really felt it
oh [ __ ] yeah I felt the gums of the
mouth like it bit my hand and I felt the
top of the of its mouth the roof of his
mouth of my fingers was all like slimy
and [ __ ] and that's when I knew I was
like I'm [ __ ] getting bit right now
so like I'm so like I fell to bite and I
go oh [ __ ] if I like pull my hand off
it's gonna take my hand so I let him
have my hand you just gave up yeah dude
I was just like dude here's my hand bro
how slow motion this experience is
unfolding because all it was yeah for
real so yeah and then dude it felt like
the strongest like a full like it felt
like someone grabbed you like with a
[ __ ] robot hand and just just like
you have no there's it was so powerful
and so muscular I don't know it was a
straight muscle it felt like a straight
muscle that just can just take my hand
off dude it was so [ __ ] gnarly like
the first thing that we stopped like
that where like was poopy's hand come up
out of the water and it's just gushing
yeah it was off and it was just like oh
[ __ ] it was like the gnarliest thing
ever and
the actual like it was a wave runner
like jet ski which the medic was driving
to toe poopies on the wakeboard off the
ramp so he was being towed yeah that was
his first toe too so so the the the
medic was driving the the jet ski toes
poopies off the ramp sees the [ __ ]
thing and the medic is on the jet ski
turns it around and drives straight back
and dives off
Dives on there like dude this medic just
dove into this this mix so [ __ ] fast
saved poopies in such a big way dude
like just no regard for himself dove in
the mix [ __ ] grab poopy's [ __ ]
okay got just got poopies out of the
water not poop this is climbing on the
boat like if you hold your hand limp
right like hold your hand limp vertical
your hand comes out horizontally so far
it can go your hand can only come out
horizontal yeah but because all in
poopy's tendons were completely severed
his hand was flopped all the way down
like all the way down to his forearm his
hand was flat to his wrist you saw this
Steve I saw I saw his hand flopped all
the way down as he got on the boat I was
like oh my gosh I try to like push up
but it like dude yeah you tried to use
your hands yeah
and then I [ __ ] lifted it up and it
fell off and I was like oh [ __ ] dude I
was like this is not good but that guy
saved my life because I don't think if
he if he didn't jump on me I would have
gotten mauled to death yeah I I don't
doubt that I don't doubt that and if
everyone didn't move so [ __ ] fast he
would have bled out definitely he had
his arteries severed was it multiple
arteries
dude I I saw blood squirting out like a
perfect straw like you spin water out of
a straw is perfect circle and so you get
on the boat they wrap you up and you're
gone like how quickly is that there's
medic
the Medics bag was on another [ __ ]
boat so they're like magic bags they'd
like go [ __ ] like and it all happened
so [ __ ] fast yeah and the clear the
current was [ __ ] so like it took me to
the side of the boat where I'm supposed
to get on it past that so now they're
like pull trying to get me on the boat
and then my wakeboard gets stuck between
these two yeah he's still on the
wakeboard
and Jeff tremaine's trying to get the
wakeboard off he goes [ __ ] I don't know
the [ __ ] get this wakeboard off I'm
like just chill just chill I'm like just
grab me a [ __ ] towel and so they've
got the wakeboard off they got me under
the boat and I'm like just give me the
[ __ ] towel everyone's freaking out
they're like they don't know what to do
I'm just give me a [ __ ] towel I wrap
it up and I just [ __ ] hold on and I I
remember one of the camera divers he's
just like just slits just lay in my just
lay in my arms everybody was so [ __ ]
Pro dude I just like it was it was a
double decker boat and I just went
straight to the top deck just like to
the other side of the boat top deck and
just put had my face in my hands I was
just like Jesus yeah I couldn't deal
with it and
what were you thinking Steve I just I
just knew that I didn't add anything I
added no value to the situation we had
the Medics we they had they got the
tournament get going dude they [ __ ]
immediately like had a you know the
speedboat showed up purpose was on the
boat probably in less than a minute
tourniquet was on you know the longest
time of that part was getting the
wakeboard off I think right and then I
got that off and then it was just like
speed boat medic back tourniquet so I
had a tourniquet on this arm
right here and then I had a tourniquet
like right here but it used to stop the
blood flow yeah yeah and then it [ __ ]
but it wasn't like working that well but
yeah luckily they gotta I [ __ ] took a
speedboat dude dude the speed boat came
in so hot to the docks dude we almost
[ __ ] like ate [ __ ] into the box
and that that one bumped my hand too
when we hit the dog bro I was like oh I
was like oh how fast were you seeing a
10 minute 10 minute boat ride to the
doctor a 10 minute boat ride to the dock
and then they had to get me in a van
which was funny and ready to go 20
minutes to the hospital and then they
got me in the hospital and they're on
like lunch break or some [ __ ] and I got
something dude keep in mind this is the
Bahamas this is not the most capable oh
[ __ ] Hospital right you know and but
they were there if they were able to
stabilize poopies at the Bahamas
hospital and they were like yo he's got
to get air lifted to uh to Miami Florida
yeah you know because I had to sign
myself out of the hospital because
there's this little Asian doctor and
he's like waiting on a phone call to
like get the approval for surgery I'm
like dude I'm not getting surgery in the
Bahamas and poopy's dad was at the
hospital in the Bahamas they wouldn't
let his dad in yeah
coronavirus or like no you can't be in
and poop his dad was [ __ ] dude I just
wanted to see someone that I knew like
it was the worst time in my life like
dude and when they when when they get
puppies on the speed boat to take him to
the to the shore I'm up on the top deck
and I see poopies on the speedboat and I
just go poopies I love you dude and uh
and [ __ ] poop is looks up he goes
[ __ ] Stevo what the [ __ ] or no he
says he says yo Tremaine what the [ __ ] I
better get a bonus for this yeah yeah I
want a [ __ ] bonus dude did you get a
bonus no no no
my phone
[Music]
the Medics are doing all their thing
right you got like tremains there you've
got like
you know Tripp Taylor was there and then
you've got like the the discovery
Discovery Channel people there so
they're [ __ ] freaking out there's
like the jackass production team and
then there's the discovery production
team which was just another production
company and the guy the executive
producer for this other production
company like whoever the main guy was he
goes oh my god dude he goes dude oh my
God we just we just ended Shark Week
like there's oh my God like there's
never gonna be Shark Week Shark Week had
had gone on for up to that point 30
years without ever anybody getting
bitten by a shark and Knox was like it
took us 30 minutes
[Applause]
yeah oh yeah I mean Jesus it's the best
documented shark bite clip in history
Perhaps Perhaps and uh and so like as
soon as this executive producer guy says
to we just had to charge shark they're
like they're the shark week's over dude
we can [ __ ] it oh my God this is the
worst [ __ ] thing and I said no
immediately this is when I snapped out
of it and I was no longer like shut down
emotionally I snapped out back
now
immediately I said no no the the the the
worst thing the only bad thing that can
happen out of this situation is if that
footage doesn't come out yeah because
this footage will make poopies a legend
and the worst possible tragedy would be
if poopy's had this happen to him and
then didn't get the credit this has to
[ __ ] come out and and we will go to
war yeah you know like whatever like
because because they figured that the
show was gonna be shut down everything
was just gonna be
and like I was like nah dude I'm just I
don't know that there would be it would
have been a lot of grounds for suing no
I mean we want to do that I'm not that
guy anyways right they must have had a
lot of views for that episode right I
mean probably the most it was
humongously successful for for they they
were thrilled and that was my debut of
Jackass and then the next day the next
day we learned that not only is Shark
Week not shut down but we're gonna go
filming purpose has been air backed you
know to Miami I was in surgery had
multiple surgeries to reattach severed
arteries and tendons all my tendons who
knows how you reattach completely
severed arteries but they did that for
two of them it's just insane and they
tell us
hey guys we're going on another shark
attack
oh yeah the next day you guys went out
huh when you were in Miami we went on
another shark dive and they're doing all
these interviews and I'm like and I'm
like dude I mean [ __ ] that uh I was
just [ __ ] Hamming it up I I was like
dude [ __ ] um let's go find the shark
we gotta go get revenge what that shark
did the poopies was not cool man we are
going back in the water to find that son
of a [ __ ] and give him a piece of our
mind yeah you know
that was not [ __ ] cool man and we are
gonna go [ __ ] but we're we're but we're
not trying to look for for Bad Blood we
just want to go squash somebody no that
wasn't cool yeah and just watch the beef
yeah yeah like and I was like I was like
poop this is probably gonna make a full
recovery and this will be the best thing
that ever happened to him yeah you
filmed that video that night at the
hotel yeah plus he got to write his
first private jet yep there you go yeah
yeah it was great yeah I'm so glad I
[ __ ] survived that thing dude are you
glad it I'm glad I still have my hand no
like imagine if I didn't have a hand
dude I'd have been like [ __ ] I'm so glad
you survived that thing too yeah I did
I'm sure everyone you were supposed to
have it fully back in October that was
now October November December January
February yeah it sounds like I'm still
going to physical therapy so it's over
six months late and it's not all the way
back six months later dude it's a shark
bite people are like oh they're like
they they treat it like it's not a shark
bite it's like a they like treat it like
it's a broken wrist or something I'm
like dude you guys this thing is like
this is all it can do you know like oh
my God you don't have [ __ ] back no dude
like I can do that that and that so if
you're just listening poopy's got about
10 degrees on going up or down on his
wrists and I can't make a fist
that's [ __ ] heartbreaking but but
you've been back in the water you're
able to serve yeah yeah I [ __ ] my
first time surfing wasn't in like in
October after my birthday so you did
surf on schedule I did surf on schedule
it wasn't really like pumping surfing it
was more like trying to see how much
weight my wrist can take did you serve
pipeline nope not yet not yet pipeline's
gnarly pipeline's not when I get a good
pipeline Barrel I'll be so [ __ ] pump
but we're still working on that so dude
like you're you're not back you're
arrested I'm not back dude like I can't
even write a short board like I have to
soft top every time like Sarah that's so
[ __ ] heartbreaking man how did that
happen I remember I felt guilty and I
had [ __ ] like no I don't know why the
[ __ ] I would feel guilty I didn't
[ __ ] you didn't do anything I didn't
put you up to it yeah
dude I I felt really [ __ ] awful about
the situation and and I was uh I was
like dude [ __ ] discoveries kind of
[ __ ] sugar coat this I knew because
when we filmed the end of that episode
they were trying to play it down like oh
yeah baseball recovery like this now and
and I it was really important to me that
you'd be able to tell that story like
actually as it happened and so I reached
out to
certain people who had the raw footage
yep and I got Legend both underwater
camera angles all of the raw footage of
the bite all of everything everything
like the gnarliest
and the gnarly clip that Discovery
didn't use it was like too gnarly for
the interviews yeah this stuff like so
that previously tell the the real story
of how it went down and and I went
around in one day I went around and I
filmed Knoxville and Tremaine and Jasper
who was there everybody who was there
and I did my own little interview with
them so awesome and then poopies did his
own interview to tell the story and we
put together this phenomenal phenomenal
video yeah about all of our perspectives
on the attack and poopy in that poopy's
telling that story was that like the
first time you told the story because
poopy's broke down well yeah the first
time I ever told the story out of a
discovery that's it we're linking that
[ __ ] video you put it on your Chanel
yeah
you gotta check it out no it's a
powerful video it's so well done and
it's the only video there's no real
feelings out that one for sure it's the
only video on here is Chanel that has
over a million
is there any part of you that you're
glad you got bit
there is there is dude like because like
like imagine my story is like I [ __ ]
got bit by a shark I jumped a [ __ ]
shark pit like Fonzie was gonna like
Fonzie did you know I like Fonzie dead
now not like
I was wondering what phones you was
wearing but yeah yeah dude I mean like
who can say they jumped a [ __ ] shark
pit with a wakeboard and [ __ ] didn't
land it and got bit and I'm lit I'm here
to tell the story right I don't think
there's anyone in the world that's ever
[ __ ] jumped a shark pit
not like you have not like me yeah yeah
and the the bite I mean yeah dude it is
heartbreaking but it's also it's
definitely like it adds to my legacy
dude as to my legacy man what are you
Limited in doing like we've established
the stripping pipeline so there's like
surfing pipes short boarding big waves
um
there's there's there's times where I'm
like trying to open the door with my
keys and like I got groceries and I
can't get my keys and like are there's
times where I'm like trying to get
something on my backpack and my arm my
wrist doesn't reach that far so there's
all these little things these little
tiny things that you wouldn't think of
that [ __ ] suck
you told me that you asked me to line
you up with stem cell therapy yeah yeah
I want to go do this when you're texting
with your phone your your hand hurts you
yeah so like in the morning time it's
fine like I'll wake up in the morning
and it feels great you know and then
I'll wake up take my shower and I'll get
on my phone and when I'm on my phone
it's just like from just like texting
and typing like my emails and [ __ ] or
just liking stuff and it just starts
hurting so then I get this ache in my
hand and I get I can't use it and then
it's like [ __ ] well I have to use it
like I have to my whole day ahead of me
you know yeah you gotta be swiping on
Tinder yeah
linked you up with Michael at bio
accelerator yeah you can talk to him
yeah I have I have and I'm let's give
them a shout out bio accelerators yeah
exceller accelerator yeah bio
accelerator dude I'm coming for you guys
you guys are gonna help me out so much
I'm so stoked that you guys want to help
me can you do a like a push-up or is
that like two no he's been practicing
like with missionary sex yeah just try
to do some pumps and yeah
it would help so much though because it
would stretch it and dude it would hurt
so much though but I was like I know I
this is this is good for it because it's
stretching it so now I can [ __ ] put
my Wrist all the way like that wow so
straight boning like was the best
Physical Therapy there yeah it was and
like I'll tell people that and they
thought I was a [ __ ] [ __ ] but it's
a good pickup line you know yeah dude it
would too because I'd put so much weight
on because I'm trying to not to and like
get in that zone you know you're like
yeah come on and then
a lot of pressure on it and then you
know and then it's like I finally not
and then it's like [ __ ] finally I gotta
like roll over and like hold my hand I'm
like oh [ __ ] babe that was great yeah
you're getting a frenzy yeah but yeah I
[ __ ] helped out a lot dude so that
that kind of I was like as long as I can
get my wrist to do that because I
couldn't need to stand up on my
surfboard I'm fine and missionary helped
out so much
I don't think I shouldn't beat [ __ ] I
don't think I should have been doing
that at that time but dude I was like I
have to nut right now and yeah that's
how I like the nut is missionary so so
what what is the physical therapist and
the doctor is telling you
physical therapist is so fried they keep
doing the same [ __ ] and doing the same
[ __ ] and I'm like dude it's a [ __ ]
shark bite dude this ain't no normal
injury you know my doctor's like poopies
dude you're a [ __ ] man dude you're
the man and he helps me out I just see
him every three weeks Dr Dan and every
three weeks you're coming up to LA to go
to like the foremost hand doctor in the
world yeah yeah so he has his um his
assistant which is a legend too and he
checks I go to Orange County at his
office okay he checks it out but he said
it's pretty much that's all I got that's
all you're ever gonna have
fun yeah so I that's what I wasn't
hoping for but I mean that's how it just
happened is it gonna get stronger to
where you can I don't know every time
you'll never be able to Surf a short
board again in your life no I will I
mean how's that girl Bethany do it
what's The Girl With One Eye she's
gnarly dude so so I have yeah she's not
she's inspiration to me
because she's got one arm dude and she's
standing up at pipe yeah shout out to
Bethany Hamilton you are a legend if you
can I describe a short documentary on an
airplane and I was really [ __ ] she's
gnarly dude she's gnarly yeah she's red
she's rad I've never really got to meet
her like in person the difference for
you though is that if you land on it bad
that it's fragile it's it's like you
know yeah because look how small it is
between this arm and that arm I mean if
you're a piping you wipe out you're [ __ ]
yeah if I yeah and I can't swim yeah so
so the hand is actually a liability word
if it wasn't there there would be you
might want to get that like uh vest that
you can just pop oh I have one of those
I've have one of those dude
anymore I'm over the big wave game I'm
on jackass now I'm I'm safer on land now
I like land it breaks my heart dude it
really [ __ ] breaks my heart to to
learn that dude
America if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do I have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
The Bucket List tour and the stuff I
filmed for this show is way too hot for
Jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy Olympics and
skyjacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com yeah
[Applause]